do you want to introduce yourself and uh
what you do oh my god that's a lot of
pressure uh uh my name is anthony
padilla some people say padilla i'm
totally fine with that but i do like to
say padilla like tortilla
that's how i get people to memorize it
um let's see so uh god how deep do we
want to go into this history here you're
youtube too
we have we have two apps we have two
houses are we doing two plus hours okay
let's get deep guys uh so i started uh
with my friend ian uh i started a
youtube channel called smosh in 2005.
17. what's smosh 17 years half of my age
ago oh my god jesus half of my age half
your life has been on half of my life
yes oh [ __ ] i'm having to rethink so
many things
i'm going to need that two and a half
hours yeah
and then in 2017 i kind of split off to
do my own thing i've been doing an
independent
channel which has slowly evolved into me
kind of doing deep dive interviews with
either groups of people or one person
that has um
you know
some kind of
popularity surrounding them right
we drill in deep into
uh
the psychology behind uh blowing up or
you know if it's a group of people
um i like to kind of get in there and
understand them yeah i feel like so many
people have preconceived ideas about
what a group or what a label or identity
means so i like to kind of show that
there is variation in nuance from
individual to individual yeah they're
really good yeah thank you i mean this
is like pretty intimidating because not
only are you like the og of youtube i
can say that you're you're like you are
you are like not even like uh it's not
even like a subjective yeah yeah it's
like objectively you are you are the og
of youtube but also you are like now the
interviewer of like youtubers and now
we're interviewing you so i'm like first
engineer this year
my stuff is so different when i came
here i was like so what are we talking
about today you're like
i don't know
when i go into mine i'm like okay okay
i've got like this 45 bullet points i
know where to get through these i i over
plan so much this is just shows the
shows though it's good yeah yeah
my favorite stuff is always the stuff
that comes out of stuff that happens in
the moment that was never planned and
that is
yeah yeah on youtube it'll say top
moment all of it yeah yeah all of you
gotta hit me when you came and you were
like so what are we talking about today
guys and we just look at each other and
we were just like what do you mean oh
[ __ ] we're talking to uh anthony today
[ __ ] he's the interviewer and we don't
have any interview questions
i was like uh do they have some kind of
secret thing that they're not telling me
some kind of prank that they're gonna do
they're like should we tell him no we're
gonna hit you with a low blow and about
just grill
how much prep do you do for your
interviews because as we've just
established we do zero zero crap here
the only the only prepping we do is who
are we getting
today yeah um let's see so the show
start i call it i spent a day with
whatever the topic or whatever the
person's name is and at first it was
like four people i would sit down with
and it would amount to like eight hours
now it's a little bit shorter like two
to three hours if it's just one guest a
little bit longer but i do a
pre-interview call which is like an hour
hour and a half or two and then i work
backwards to try to figure out what
we're going to talk what questions i'm
going to come up with based on the
things that we talked about so yeah
god i cannot even of pressure yeah what
made you start doing pre-interviews is
it because you maybe had some guests
somewhere you're like [ __ ] i could have
done a way better job like a little bit
of that it was also uh bringing on
guests that
have really big stories and i felt like
i couldn't just go in there and be like
so um tell me about your childhood and
then just like did they just go and i'm
like i think they probably got
everything like i i also i realized that
in the interviews i was cutting out a
lot of stuff right right you know i was
like it's a lot of me trying to figure
out where this is going i kind of want
to have an idea of where we're going
first yeah and i realized uh that i was
like every night before
the the next day was an interview i
would be like up until 4am like 12 hours
straight like [ __ ] i don't know what i'm
talking about i got to learn every
single thing about this person's life
like drill down you know i interviewed
youtubers that's actually how i found
out about this podcast i saw you had
interviewed some a v tour as well oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly um
and i like i watched that episode and i
was like learning everything about
vtubers i was like wait i could just
talk to them have them tell me the
important things and then i could
reverse engineer the questions based on
the conversations that they want to have
yeah so basically you you take out some
of the research time where you don't
even know if you're going down like the
wrong rabbit horse yes and instead you
just come straight from the source i
guess yes yeah and then i'm able to use
the extra time that i now have during
the interviews
to uh kind of drill in deeper to like um
like this the psychology behind the
feelings that they were having and what
things affected them from those moments
and how they affect them now yeah and i
guess it just allows me to get a little
bit deeper with the conversations yeah
so like yeah so like the interviews are
like 20 to 40 minutes how much of that
is like how much source like footage do
you have how much of it gets cut out you
reckon yeah uh so it depends the person
uh markiplier we shot like two hours and
40 minutes and we cut it down to a half
hour somehow miraculously after it came
out he was like holy [ __ ] you did it you
bastard
but uh we apparently like were able to
get all the the key components the
conversations that were
really meaty have them in there while
cutting out all the fluff and it's it's
a it's a lot of there's a big process
that we have uh
we have five editors now it goes it goes
from person to they all have like a very
specific
uh they're like a specific cog in the
machine yeah and uh it's a lot of just
like grinding it down it goes to the
first person they get the full two and a
half hours of footage they cut it down
to 50 and then it's like that person
cuts it down and each person is like
really good at refining we just have a
one-man machine
yeah yeah he's like he he works like 10
people's work he's just like i'll do it
myself yeah damn
i do have a solution to that problem you
know if you if you're like coming in
with like two and a half hours of
footage and uh having a hard time
cutting it down oh yeah have you ever
thought about this thing called a
podcast
you mean just releasing it
i thought about no cuts
i have thought about that and people
have asked they're like come on just
release the full thing i know you got it
there somewhere uh but i feel like i'm
too much of a stickler for like i want
it to really be polished i want
everything that i come out with to feel
polished i know that i know there's an
environment where people want
longer conversations that are unedited
like this one obviously has a huge
audience even on youtube where i feel
like people are not generally looking
for very long uncut things you guys
found that audience and it does exist
yeah but i just i really want something
that feels a little bit more a little
bit more bite-sized but you could like
take those like cut parts that you cut
out for example turn it into like a
compilation release it on like patreon
for like behind the scenes oh yeah yeah
have you thought about doing that for
sure yeah we definitely have a bunch of
like archived conversations that
we are noting this didn't really make
the cut yeah it is still a strong
conversation i mean with with the amount
of questions i guess you're asking and
the amount of people you're asking i'm
sure there's moments there you're like
that question didn't go down great oh
that was a little awkward let's just cut
that out just start a little bit but
some well it depends sometimes the
awkward questions and answers have like
yeah are the best ones because it force
it puts me on the spot to come up with
something that was unplanned
and i uh
i overthink everything that i usually do
that it's the unplanned stuff that
actually gets the like gets out of my
head because i'm actually you know there
in the moment yeah uh but yeah sometimes
it's i just move right on yeah you're
like all right next
question keep me in keep keep it in of
me being like uh so anyway uh
me not knowing where to go with it like
when i interviewed dominatrixes and some
of the details that they said yeah uh i
didn't i don't think there was any
response that would have felt
appropriate in that moment right about
some of the actions that went down
behind the scenes
yeah i'm i think i'm a little too
vanilla to have uh been prepared for
yeah
is there a lot you have to cut out to
let's say
keep within youtube guidelines
i mean to a certain degree yes sometimes
we just censor it and that's enough yeah
because we don't want the video to be
age gated and yeah
no one sees this video right um
i mean certain episodes yeah i spent a
day with strippers yeah dominatrixes
you i mean i'm gonna have a an upcoming
episode i spent a day with pony players
look it up actually or maybe not maybe
with us private maybe with a private
browser incognito window what is a pony
player
so they are people that uh it's
basically role play it's a little bit of
uh dom and sub dynamic
and they dress up as a pony kind of in a
leather another like flight my little
uh like
oh just like an actual pony think about
a humanoid oh here we go we got we got
some visuals for you
can you click on that black and white
one there i think that one's a pretty
good dynamic yeah let's let's let's zoom
in on
uh
twitter
take a look oh wow
yeah
we don't put these off it's like uh it's
like a leather furry a little bit um
except it's bdsm so it's not a furry
because those are not always associated
with anything sexually
i mean a little bit yeah it's uh my
producer elise she's like uh
so we got this really interesting person
she has a um an arena you know where
horses usually um reside in but it's for
the pony players do you want to do you
want to add on a little segment where
you go on location i was like
yeah let's do it
i didn't know how to react to that but
the obvious answer is yes right
it's the context yeah i mean yeah when i
when i do a lot of episodes i spend it
with dominatrixes i'm like
you have to dominate me like that's hard
that's power into this but you have to
do it
clearly anthony just wanted to know what
this was like or like clearly anthony's
a pro at this because he didn't really
have that big of a reaction i was like i
i mean you know transparently i just
wanted it's part i wanted to learn about
in the scene i have to put myself in it
to really understand cool dynamic of why
people would do this what do they take
out of it yeah what do they like about
it